- Please welcome, Michelle Buteau.
(audience applauding)
- Out of time!
- I had the privilege of working with you
and it was the last film I've done
and probably will do for a little while.
- I was so intimidated
being on set with you
and it was also my first
jump back into work
when the babies were born.
The babies were six weeks old
and at that point it was
just like, every two hours.
It was just like crazy,
we need bottles, diapers.
But, I just remember thinking at one point
you brought your daughter to set
and it was an overnight shoot
and it wasn't too late yet
and I was like, this is what it is, right?
This is how you sort of, do it all.
You sort of try to make
time for everybody.
And it looked like you guys were so close,
like you almost had your own language.
And I'm like, this is so beautiful.
And I feel like, also to
see you in your element,
you know, motherhood and also acting.
That's the best education
anybody could ever have,
you know what I mean?
So, thank you for that.
It was really fun.
I mean, I hope we get to work again.
- I would give anything
to collaborate with you.
It's so funny how we all
scramble so much as women.
And here's what's so funny,
is I don't feel like men do that scramble.
Why don't men flip out
about all the details?
And why do we?
- I do think it's a biological thing.
And I hate to say that,
because I don't want this to turn into
an episode of "Everybody Loves Raymond",
but I think it just is.
When my kid cries, I know
what kind of cry that is.
I'm like, "They're hungry,
they're needy, they're bored,
"they've hurt themselves."
I even know the cry and I'm not relaxed
until I help them relax.
Watching you, I was like,
okay this is what it is.
You can have a handle
on it, you can leave,
you can bring them,
you can make it happen.
It really is, I think,
creating their own world
and level of comfort for what you can do
and not being caught in
everyone else's rat race.
Because, quite frankly,
that's just going to age me.
- I love how when your man, who is Dutch
and you guys have furniture
store in Van Der Most Modern
in Brooklyn.
- Yes!
It's really fun to go help somebody
make their house what they
thought they could make it.
If that makes sense.
- How did you meet your man?
- Oh girl!
Well my mom's watching, bleh!
(laughing) I was out one night,
and you know, dippin'
and doin' it, dancin',
he was spinning me,
buying expensive drinks.
Very overprices margaritas,
yes, using real lime.
And we just sort of kept
in touch (chuckles).
- Now were you a fan of reality TV
because obviously "The
Circle" is a big phenomenon
and you're actually
getting on a plane tomorrow
to go back to Manchester
to film season two.
- Yes, I think it's not only a fun watch
but it's also really important.
What happens when you have
to engage in social media?
You also realize the back
stories behind catfishing
where people don't feel worthy
to show who they really
are on social media.
Which is really sad too, and
that begs the question, why?
You know, we are always enough!
Like be kind to each other.
You can say all these comments, right?
But, just think about it
because this is someone's
son or someone's daughter.
So, I really love being
a part of "The Circle"
and I cannot wait to see
what kind of characters
they've casted for season two.
- Oh, and your book, by the way,
comes out in December, oh my God!
"Survival of the Thickest"!
- Yeah! I wrote a book!
What is wrong with her, she wrote a book?
It's called "Survival of the Thickest".
It's plus-sized essays
in a small-minded world.
And it's available for pre-order
and comes out December 8th,
just in time for Hanukkah,
Christmas, Kwanza
and non-denominational whatever.
It's stories that don't
necessarily fit on stage.
But for better or for worse,
I've found that there's real
power in sharing your truth.
So this was a moment, this was a moment.
And I hope people read it and enjoy it.
Or at least talk about it over Zoom.
- Well I now know what
I am doing for Christmas
'cause before I had my
kids I was a real weirdo.
I didn't really hang out
with anyone on Christmas.
It was time for me to kind
of catch up on solo time.
But I would always read a book.
And it would be like,
"Letters to a Young Poet"
by Rainer Maria Rilke,
like really heavy stuff.
And then one Christmas I discovered
"Holidays On Ice" by David Sedaris.
- My favorite.
- And I was like, why am I
reading such heavy stuff?
Why am I being so bah humbug on Christmas?
I need to lighten up, so I am so excited.
This is going to be the
best Christmas read ever.
I'm going to pre-order
today, I'm so excited.
Thank you
- Oh my goodness.
- so much Michelle.
- Thank you! I love you so much, girl!
- All right, Michelle Buteau.
"Welcome to Buteaupia" is on Netflix now.
Pre-order Michelle's book,
"Survival of the Thickest"
and obviously "The Circle"
is available on Netflix
and Michelle is leaving
to go film season two,
right after this.
(upbeat music)